hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast you know what [__] this [__]
podcast
I swear to God my [__] stupid ass
[__] thing never [__] works for I
I gotta record it on my phone this
[__] thing the computer it says like
an echo voice I can't get rid of it and
I can't even forward the [__] [__]
that I did so I gotta start all over
again and over the [__] time to do it
I swear to God this [__] technology
[__] how does it make your life easier I
literally every [__] thing before you
go to bed you gotta [__] spend 700 on
[__] electricity making sure every
[__] thing is charged or you can't
record you can't [__] do anything
look at this [__] [__]
this isn't even a podcast you're just
listening to me losing my [__] mind
about the 9 millionth time and now my
[__] laptop which I only got a year
and a half ago it's already starting to
slow down
you know
it's already starting to [__] slow
down
oh yeah it's obsolete is it you [__]
Apple [__]
foreign
do you think there's ever going to be a
time when any sort of politician grows
some [__] balls and the general
population gets their [__] heads out
of their asses and they stop rooting for
republicans and Democrats and realize
that these [__] stupid ass spineless
[__] politicians who only give a [__]
about whatever golden parachute they're
going to get from the corporate [__]
that's [__] paying them to push
whatever agenda they have through the
[__] machine oh
tear
you know somebody just told me why L.A
L.A has like the most expensive [__]
real estate
I guess we just surpassed San Francisco
somehow
a city with no [__] water supply is
global warming is is
every [__] is is
gonna destroy this place for some reason
nobody I know can afford a [__] house
out here anymore and it's they finally
just said this Corporation groups out
here that are just buying up houses for
cash to then turn around and rent them
so basically they'll outbid any normal
[__] person out here so essentially
the last part of the American dream
being able to own a house
is going to go away and these
politicians are just going to sit back
and let them [__] do it because the
same [__] Corporation that's buying
up all of those houses is going to
[__] line the pockets of these
[__] piece of [__] politicians
they're all [__] scumbags every
[__] one of them unless you know you
know you know you realize a politician
is in a scumbag he's called this he's
immediately branded a socialist or a
communist if he wants to do anything
anything for the people if he wants to
[__] you know take on the bankers and
have them be [__] accountable if he
wants to do anything on that [__] oh
this guy's a [__] socialist and all
you [__] mouth breathing morons
believe it
you know what I really enjoy actually
the fact that they [__] on communism and
they act like capitalism is working
but capitalism works that we we are we
are so [__] broke
it doesn't even every August no one pays
attention to it all of the politicians
just sit around going like is this it is
this the end of the country and at the
last second they go ah print more money
right and then everything why is it like
[__] 9.50 for a one slice of bread
I'll tell you why it's because that guy
doesn't have on the right colored tie
ah sorry all right I'm done let's get
back to bread and circus we'll talk
about how well the Boston Bruins are
playing
I just can't [__] believe it man
I just cannot [__] believe
you know I went out here I got this
[__] setup out here in my garage
everything's all [__] set up and you
just think like okay I'm good
I'm good nope nope you're not good
you're not [__] good you know what
you're never gonna be good
it's never gonna [__] work
this [__] thing has worked 20 percent
of the [__] time since I've had it
you know and then for some reason I have
a charger for the [__] the the the
the the the hard drive [__] part of
it but I don't have no I have one for
the keyboard but not for the mouse it's
the same [__] chord so now I gotta go
out and go buy another [__] cord
right so I can [__] plug that [__]
thing to make sure everything's all
[__] charged up and then you know
what happens you know what happens the
[__] power goes out the whole thing
gets wiped clean and then I gotta sit
around I gotta [__] start all over
again with this thing [__] this thing
[__] all of this
unfucking believable
I believe yeah so that's what they're
doing now corporations are buying up
houses corporations
are buying up houses so the Regular Joe
can't buy a [__] house and guess what
Republicans don't care Democrats don't
care nobody [__] cares none of them
give a [__] all they want is their house
in Martha's Vineyard or their [__]
aquifers in the South South America
that's all they give a [__] about
they're in it for themselves we had some
[__] Rich [__] out here running for
[__] office and everybody thought
that he was going to be the savior
people are so dumb it's like a guy's a
real estate developer he spends a
hundred million dollars of his own money
to get a job that pays 250 Grand a year
and everybody oh of course he likes La
that much Jesus wake the [__] up
he's spending 100 million so he can give
his own company 4 billion in Real Estate
jobs
well you know those jobs are going to
create our jobs
no they're going to grossly underpay you
and then the corporation itself is going
to go out and buy houses and outbid you
in cash
so how do you fight back against it you
know what
don't sell your house to a corporation
how about that
how about that how about you do one for
The Regular Guy
and you take the offer from the hard
work and you're not going to do it
you're not going to do it because that
that's how capitalism works
[__] everybody else below me I'm getting
mine that's how it [__] works and it
doesn't [__] work communism doesn't
none of them work none of them work
because all forms of government are run
by human beings
and we're all [__] flawed that's what
it is and you know who you can blame you
can blame God for that because that's
how he makes people he takes every each
and every one of us out of the oven too
early and then we come down here and
we're all [__] up and we just do crazy
[__]
I think he just sits back and [__]
enjoys it all right so [__] every
religion and all you dumb songs to this
invisible guy who didn't make your right
to begin with that's how [__] up you
are you're actually singing songs to
somebody who did a bad job on you
ah
this is how far I take it this is how
far I take
my little podcast Studio
not running not working the way that I
want it to work and maybe if I took
[__] 10 minutes and slowed down my
scatter brain I could actually learn how
it worked and I could maybe you know
charge my mouse and [__] figure it
out
you know
and not have this psycho echo on my
voice and and I don't even know what
why doesn't it interest me
I have absolutely no interest
in
any of that [__] laptops iPhones
all of this [__] but all of
the world runs on them so I have to
interact with them and I'll tell you
this dude if I see that [__] robot
going down the street one more time I
just like I I literally watched this old
guy having to slow down and speed up his
gate
this homeless guy trying to get around
this robot as the robot was trying to
negotiate the [__] uneven sidewalks
and he's already like subservient to the
thing he's treating it like it's a
person
you're like well hey you know I don't
want to
bump into this this is somebody else's
property and blah blah blah
you know
and when you look at those two things
you know that other person actually has
empathy unlike that [__] toaster
rolling down the [__] street but the
toaster doesn't want to be part of a
union and doesn't want weekends and
holidays off so that [__] nice guy is
he's going to become extinct that's
what's going to happen maybe that's what
I'll do I'll just enjoy
you know these rich [__]
it's just I don't know you know another
thing too is I had a really good friend
of mine die
um I got to give a shout out to Diana
Linden
um
who was number one I ever talked about
how I had this Jedi masseuse
she got rid of my sciatic nerve
problems she my back was all twisted my
shoulders up rotator cuff frozen
shoulder all of that she got rid of all
of that the quality of life that I got
because she was an absolute Jedi next
level
um masseuse
who just did everything for everybody
else and you know
always put everybody before herself she
just was an amazing person and she
passed away uh yesterday
at the ripe old age of 75.
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking like your masseuse was 75
strong like bull
oh my God her [__] elbow she'd have
me coming up off the table because I
mean I literally came in there
maybe having gotten five half-assed
massages in my life I came in with like
almost half a century of problems and
she gradually undid all of them most of
which that if I went to a doctor they
would have they would have operated on
my back or my shoulders and all of that
[__] you know they staple your [__]
rotator cuffs back to get all of this
[__] that they do or whatever
she was able to um
work all of that out everybody told me I
was going to have sciatic nerve problems
for the rest of my life and uh I didn't
because of her and her wonderful work
and unfortunately she passed away
yesterday so rest in peace Diana
um I love you you were the best thank
you
for everything you did for me and you
made my life the quality of my life I'll
be forever thankful
to you
um
anyway so I went to a um
a premiere of
um
the uh the Mandalorian
on uh Tuesday they showed us the first
two episodes of this season
and I think all you Star Wars freaks are
going to be more than happy
I can tell you that
um I will tell you Star Wars fans are
[__] cool
you know what I mean they're energy like
when you go down there they're really
polite they're kind of quiet and a
little awkward it is just the exact
opposite energy
that I get when I meet the usual sports
fan who's a meathead like me it's like
they're like loud aggressive
yeah
yeah it's like hey y'all Mr Pearl I just
I don't want to bother you I really
enjoy what you work on the Mandalorian
I'm like oh thanks a lot I really
appreciate it
and they then they reach behind
themselves Like Bugs Bunny and pull out
like a Mandalorian helmet like where the
[__] did that come from and then sports
fans
well they'll be like driving by by hey
Billy fat tits go [__] yourself
do you know how many times that has
happened to me
when and there's been other people on
the sidewalk
and they'll just hear somebody like
insult the [__] out of me and tell me to
go [__] myself and then I turn around I
go hey how you doing thank you
[Laughter]
it's kind of my favorite thing I was
actually
um
I had an acting gig one time
I forget which one I was whatever the
[__] I don't even know where the hell I
was I was in some City
and like for the third time on the shoot
like somebody driven by and yelled and
told me to go [__] myself and I turned
around and wave
and the actress that I was working with
just started laughing and she goes
she goes is that how your fans like your
face
your fans love you but they say really
mean stuff to you I was like yeah I know
I know I kind of uh
kind of created that culture on my
podcast and it just became like this
running joke and then people on the set
say Bill go [__] yourself and I believe
good morning
um anyway here's something else that I
learned that I'm trying to learn
is um
you know like most comedians or
performers I have this crushing need to
be liked
and
um
I never really examined it and I now
realize that you know it just comes from
you know hey if somebody likes me then
they're not gonna hurt me you know like
that type of [__] so it's uh it's
actually a weakness
so I'm trying to get rid of that and I
and I'm really starting to be okay with
like if somebody doesn't like me
I'm just rather than walking around
muttering about them I'm just going to
be like well you know not everybody's
gonna like you I mean that's what I do
with jokes that's what I do with
anything I've done on TV or anything
like this couple of movie things I've
done that's just how you know not
everybody's gonna like it but if enough
people like when people uh it took me a
while like you know you'd put out a
special
you know 10 people out I was great when
people that [__] sucked don't quit
your day Jenny just focus on that I kind
of learned
to do that with like stand up and [__]
like all right well I mean you know if
10 out of 11 people like it I'm [__]
killing it so
I have to do that with uh
I got to do that with people
and
you know because if I get like a weird
vibe from somebody I used to like
you know
all right well then I'll [__] give
you a weird vibe back and then I'm gonna
drive around in my car and say all the
stuff fantasizing that I'm winning this
[__] argument and like the person
isn't even there I'm by myself it's like
it's literally insane
so
now I'm just I'm just gonna be like all
right you don't like me that's
hey I get it
I don't like me either
um
yeah so that's that's that's my my next
my next thing and and I mean the real
deal because I can handle anything in
this business somebody not liking me but
show business is not real I mean it is
real but it's it's just [__] I mean
the real deal like in life
um
you know I'm just like all right I'm uh
I'm good with that [__] you know
I'm not good with it obviously I'm not
good with it I'm gonna be talking about
it but I I need to like [__]
learn how to do that so recently
you know
I ran into somebody
and just that Vibe was just [__]
weird and then I just sit there and take
all of it on that it's got to be
something that I'm doing or whatever and
I was just like you know I don't why the
[__] do I know what's going on in their
life
I will literally invent an entire
[__] scenario in my head
and if you're sitting right now and
you're listening to it going like this
guy is [__] nuts yeah I am
I am [__] nuts human beings are not
we're all mentally ill on some [__]
level there's just it's like being like
a functional alcoholic
because I'm not outside you know yelling
at a stop sign
I'm all right you know
I'm a [__] solid guy
you know meanwhile I'm in my car arguing
with somebody
who pissed me off 40 years ago
right
and then like
just imagine that brain running a nation
there's no way they they all do it just
think about that just picture just
picture every [__] president
walking around
in their in their boxers that little
stupid presidential seal on it so they
can feel special
as they help drive the [__] steer the
ship into the [__]
rocks
just picture them talking to themselves
you know Joe Biden Jesus Christ you
can't even that guy's like
I should be in a home
you know Donald Trump yeah me
can't you just picture that guy walking
around
eating McDonald's fries out of a big bag
but by himself
no one ever did it better
you you are the greatest you are the
greatest president that he was mentally
ill
you know
Obama's mentally ill right
you talk like somebody pulled a string
on the side of his neck
um
George W bush out of his [__] mind
lunatic [__] lunatic Bill Clinton
oh
[__] lunatic [__] lunatic
George Herbert Walker Bush war hero
flew [__] Missions at 18 years of age
where his roommate wouldn't even come
back and he had to shake that off and he
was painted as weak
handled Saddam Hussein without getting
us into a never-ending [__] War
Ronald Reagan former actor you know
I love how he gets credit for defeating
communism it's like it still exists
Russia still exists there's still a
problem yeah but he beat [__] stopped
him for a couple of years though didn't
he
it's like it's not over it's it's it's
like Ohio State first Michigan State the
game is played every year
it's another game isn't over
and that's that
um Jimmy Carter
Jimmy Carter he's peanut farmer you know
he was talking himself in the fields but
that [__] guy
that guy was the the greatest human
being that's been president since I was
President Joe Ford was all right
Nixon was a paranoid lunatic which is a
[__] shame because he would have won
the election anyway
and he had a brilliant mind for foreign
policy
and then I don't know about anybody
before that then I was too [__] young
lunatics
right
my podcast setup didn't work today so
I've attacked God in every standing
president
back to Lyndon Johnson
um I love that he grew his hair out in
the end
but you know what to say you can't beat
him he join him
uh Someday I'm gonna post that I'm gonna
be able to I'm Gonna Save that first
five minutes
I had this Echo this Reverb and I sang
the Summer Wind
I gave a halftime speech as a coach
of a team that did not do well in the
first half I I had a [__] ball
um
anyway I do the reads here but nothing
of that why don't I you know every night
I sit there and I think to myself you
know you should charge all your [__]
bill
you should [__] charge it but I don't
do it I don't do it and then I have the
nerve to [__] flip out
all right let's do this thing oh look
who it is rocket money rocket money fly
into your pockets away from the bankers
the average person has 12 page
subscriptions
think about that pause for two seconds
and if you think
sorry I started the note wrong and I
just went into the woods
um if you think you're only subscribed
to a handful of services well you might
want to double check
with rocket money you can quickly
identify and cancel
oh Jesus the white ladies are perking up
we get to cancel something all of your
unwanted subscriptions rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscriptions
they forgot about how about a shout out
for those 20 percent
huh
the people that are on the ball the
misers
that's what you call somebody that
actually is good with money you [__]
Miser
um you know because what are you gonna
do admit that they're better at it than
you are that's not a human thing to do
um where the hell is it the average
person
uh like that streaming service you
bought to watch just one show or that
free trial that you never even used yeah
and then it rolled into a subscription
rocket money will quickly eat and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you can stop paying for the ones you
don't want simply find the subscription
you don't want and press cancel
and Rocket money will cancel it for you
no more long hold times
no more hiccups during the read why do I
have hiccups
um
with customer service
or tedious emailing back and forth all
of that crap you don't have to deal with
it you just hit cancel and Rocket money
makes canceling subscription as easy as
a click of a button over three million
people
have used rocket money [__]
sorry I have this silent hiccups
saving the average person up to 720 a
year stop throwing your money away you
son of a [__] cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
that's rocketmoney.com rocketmoney.com
rocket is spelled
r-o-c-k-e-t all right just for you
poison fans out there who've been
looking at Ricky Rockets name for so
long you forgot how to spell it
maybe all the double letters we're
double levers big in the 80s let's see
here r i k k i r o
Ricky rocket r-i-k-k-i-r-o-c-k
a rock
ett
a Ricky rocket and he's rocking it he's
rocking the drums you get it you know I
saw him I stayed I stood on the side of
the stage and I saw him
on that tour
with Motley Crue Def Leppard and Joan
Jett
and uh
I gotta tell you that Key's a big guy
like a tall [__] dude way bigger than
I thought
um
a fantastic [__] drummer by the way
somebody sent me a um
somebody sent me a link
of John Bonham's drums isolated
um
on a whole lot of love
holy [__]
I mean the guy is yelling when he does
Phils
it was a bounce bounce Bonk a bad bones
if we go down the [__] drums it was
like how did that not get into the mix
just completely
immersed in what he was doing
any sort of self-consciousness or
anything just out the [__] window
um I will I will tell you this though
hmm
I was of the belief
that Ginger Baker was just a [__] and
that was it
you know and there was all this talk
about what a [__] great drummer he
was in all of that [__] and I would
listen to the cream stuff and I would be
like all right
I mean I love cream they're a great
group but I would listen to him playing
and I was just like I don't understand
what the what all of his [__]
yammering on about
how [__] great he is
and um
yeah I wasn't even a fan
so the other day I'm at the gym
and
they had this drum solo was playing and
I finally I was like who the [__] is
this this guy's unbelievable
and it was cream it was a live version
of that solo toad
and I was listening to it and I was like
all right okay I get it now
I get it I mean
I don't think that he should have gone
at John Bonham and say that he couldn't
swing a sack of [__] but I don't think
that that just still I can't say that
without laughing well John boner
couldn't swing a sack of [__]
I mean that was like a comedian
you know when you watch a comedian
making fun of [__] you're not supposed
to make fun of like you're not supposed
to make fun of John Bonham
especially as a drummer and for him to
just [__] talk about him like
you know he was like some dad drummer
like me going to Guitar Center we're all
like John Bonham couldn't swing a second
[__] John Bonham couldn't swing a second
I remember I actually got invited to go
see a screening of that and when I saw
him say that I almost fell out of my
chair laughing
at first it was the shock
and then
I was just like oh my God that's [__]
amazing it's amazing that he said that
because you're not supposed to say that
no one has ever said that publicly
um
although Keith Richards kind of trashed
him he kind of trashed Led Zeppelin you
could tell he never even listened to the
group either
because he goes Led Zeppelin he goes
aptly name because they never got off
the ground
like it's like yeah Keith that was the
joke they deliberately were making fun
of themselves naming
and he goes because they never got off
the ground and he's making this these
eyes like um
very observant Keef
um
so anyway I actually when I watched that
now
you know
having begun to pick apart my [__]
diseased brain I'm just looking this guy
going oh this guy was unbelievably
insecure
this is all basic psych 101 stuff and
Incredibly jealous
I would think as the years went by and
Bonham just became more and more
of a god
um
and less and less people I think you
know we're talking about him in
comparison I think that that sort of
built up
I got to be honest with you Ginger Baker
was not good for gingers
[Laughter]
he kind of fed into all the stereotypes
you know
we got the red hair we got a temper
where you know we're the devil
um we're not human you should kick us in
the leg you know on a special day every
[__] year he kind of like
yeah he didn't he he really didn't do us
he did us a disservice but I will tell
you this so
I did see him play a drum solo when they
they got together uh when they reformed
um I should I don't know why I didn't
see them and I didn't go see the police
like they're never going to get back
together now like you know Eric Clapton
is the only one left in cream
um
I don't know why I never [__] saw
those guys
you know why I'll tell you why I never
saw him you know why because I'm tired
that's literally the reason I didn't go
see all those great artists I was I'm at
the age I'm just too [__] tired
even back in the day you had to go down
to the record store and stand in line to
get tickets I can't even open a [__]
laptop because God knows I didn't charge
the [__] thing to just go out and buy
some goddamn tickets
um
so I'm out here in my little garage
podcast Studio look at look at all of
this [__] I have like
three different things to carry cigars
around I am this this little ledge here
is gonna be and I got boxes of cigars on
top of my fridge
that people you know have given me and
all of that [__] I'm getting rid of all
of this [__]
[__] I I kind of have an urge to do that
let's see if I do it I'm definitely
doing it with the cigars but I haven't I
have an entire bookshelf of [__]
books
um
it's like what am I going to read them
again I gotta get rid of this [__]
although I do have a good one here
John Bonham by Mick Bonham
I mean how do you throw that out I mean
that's his brother I can't throw that
one out you want to hear my books I'm
dying up here
to be the man you got to beat the man
the Ric Flair autobiography Led Zeppelin
when
giants walk the earth
rocks Joe Perry autobiography Dirty
Deeds the AC DC this is some [__]
heavy reading here people Stephen
Adler's autobiography
the Beastie Boy book
Texas flood the Stevie Ray Vaughan story
um
Bill Walsh finding The Winning Edge
it was a gift
somebody gave me
Led Zeppelin 1975.
New Orleans Sports
I what the [__] did I I got the history
of the AFL I got a Bobby Orr book I mean
you would think that I was in the
seventh grade
not a lot of heavy lifting on that shelf
huh you could pick that whole bookshelf
up with the books by yourself in your
80s
I got a book on all the old baseball
stadiums keeping that one I have my map
my Rand McNally map from when I was a
[__] road comic before all of this
GPS [__]
I've got a bunch of football cards what
the [__] is wrong with me all right
that's it that's the podcast go [__]
yourselves enjoy the music have a great
weekend you [__] and I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on
it's Bill Byrne it's the Monday Morning
podcast sorry for the [__] March 2nd
I gotta tell you something
oh I'm coming out of the gate this week
people I just [__]
I just did like eight minutes a great
[__] eight minutes a great [__]
riff the whole goddamn thing and then I
look down in the [__] goddamn stupid
ass [__] thing isn't even on
you know why this is the exact same
[__] device I had the Olympus ls10
now it's the Olympus 14. and wouldn't
you [__] know
they couldn't just leave well enough
alone they got to add like 20 [__]
steps in some stupid broads [__]
voice in there telling me what I know
I'm doing
so I [__] riff for like eight [__]
minutes and I find out the thing is even
[__] recording I I [__] I hate
technology okay I absolutely I don't
understand why do we keep going forward
all right we got enough [__] this is as
comfortable as it's gonna [__] get
why can't we just have this [__] and
this is how it [__] works and when
you figure something out that's you know
how it [__] works
Jesus [__] Christ I told you guys and
I [__] will never stop bitching about
these things I [__] uh
was talking on my podcast saying how you
know I needed a new pair of [__]
headphones one week right so uh some
[__] person who listens to the
podcast ended up sending me a pair of
[__] Wireless [__] headphones
wireless [__] headphones and I gotta
tell you I've never had more [__]
problems with something in my life
you [__] sitting there my whole life
headphones [__] work you plug them
into something that's charged the
headphones never the amount of [__]
times I sat there with my phone
listening to [__] music
my phone is charged and then the
headphones went out and I couldn't
listen it's just [__] why did you add
that step
electronic pencil sharpeners and all
that [__] and now it's just something
that's gonna [__] that drives me up
the other one the other pencil sharpener
you could buy a pencil sharpener once
and you could have that thing for 100
[__] years
and little kids could walk up this was
my grandfather's
but he used to you know [__] sharpen
pencils and then when he built stuff
when we still had good wood in this
country right it wasn't all wet because
it was brand new [__] trees it was
old [__]
oh my God I was in such a great [__]
mood
it's completely changed the whole
[__] Vibe of this goddamn thing
anyways
let me relax calm down let me try to get
back to where I was I was in such a
[__] great mood because I'm back out
here and lost Congolese
let me make sure this thing's recording
let me make sure everything's okay
and the goddamn nerve center here you
know
[__] anyways I'm back out here in L.A
it's so [__] awesome because I was
just in New York City
right
I uh I flew back there and I did night
it too many [__] stuff
and I gotta tell you that show lives up
to its name
I was standing backstage in the green
room and I couldn't believe how many
people [__] came back there
John Bon Jovi Steve Buscemi Chris Rock
Louis C.K on and on and on and on and on
I think one of the guys with the long
hair I think he might have been the
keyboard player for Bon Jovi I don't
know who the [__] he was
amazing right
I had my autograph booked out
I'm kidding anyways uh Will Forte I got
to uh got to talk to him
and uh
you know that guy's one of my favorites
and last night I actually watched his uh
his new show last man on Earth and it's
so [__] funny
it's just uh God damn it I said such
nice things though not the last [__]
time you know now I'm just trying to
remember what the [__] I said because
this stupid ass [__] recorder let me
just [__] just speak from the Hat
here like that guy is so [__]
original and he he commits so hard to
everything he does
I'm such a [__] huge fan of his and
uh
I talked to him briefly backstage I'm
gonna try to get him on the podcast I
just want to find out how the [__] he
got something this original on a major
Network
they usually freak the [__] out like
they always say they want to do
something new
you know they always say they want to do
something new but in the end you know
they [__] cut it down and everybody
gives them [__] but I get it
I get it
you know what I mean everybody's Brave
with somebody else's [__] money but
when it's your money and your job on the
line you're going to go with what has
worked in the past
I'm sorry my voice is still cracking so
I get what the [__] they do you know
what I mean I got I got this whole new
bit that I'm going to be doing about
fatties and [__] ugly people who are
[__] moaning and complaining that
beautiful people are in movies it's like
yeah you know what why don't you go put
your [__] million dollars up and go
put some troll up there I mean give me a
[__] break it's what it is
do you think I sit here wondering why is
a balding redheaded male I'm not a
[__] love interest in a movie I don't
I get it you know why because it was my
[__] zillion dollars I wouldn't cast
me either everybody [__] [__]
moaning and complaining
get on a treadmill and shut the [__] up
all right we're all out there eating
salads you think we want to do it we
don't it's part of the [__] business
you know why don't they just slow down
the [__] NBA and lower the rim so you
can play in that too
[__] unreal anyways let me plow ahead
here
oh that's gonna be a fun chunk of
material I got I got oh Jesus Christ I
got a vent on that one tonight I'm going
up and I'm [__] talking about that I
can't wait
see that that's me rubbing my hands
together with a microphone on my hand
anyways
last man on Earth is uh is absolutely uh
you know you know when you're searching
for a new show I still been searching
ever since Breaking Bad went off the air
you know what I mean just trying to you
know I saw the killing killing was great
then I blew through that because it's
[__] Netflix right they got all of
them
they turn you into a junkie right
instead of just giving you a little bit
a week and you keep your Habit in
control like the networks [__]
Netflix you just sit there you know
you'll lose a week of your life
um so anyways I gotta watch this and
then I got I gotta get caught up on uh
Better Call Saul because I was overseas
when it came out and uh I'm really bad
with with you know looking [__] up on
the internet and trying to find out
where to watch it I want to watch it
legally
um if anybody knows where I can watch
like the first two episodes because I'm
now taping the series
um really excited but uh I'm gonna do
one little spoiler thing on Last Man on
Earth all right it's gonna go down here
in about two [__] well I'll do the
it's going down right now all right so
[__] stick your fingers in here I'm
gonna time this out perfectly
10 seconds I'm gonna say it all right in
three two one Kristen Shaw is also on it
she absolutely [__] kills it and blew
me away with their acting and I'm just
so [__] psyched whenever I see a
stand-up comic or comedians in general
showing this industry that we are
actually can really be good actors they
[__] kill it I absolutely love the
show please watch it all right done okay
anyways
um
plowing ahead here uh so all right I'm
over the technology thing I'm actually
in such a [__] great mood after being
back in New York
uh which I loved
you know taking the subway and [__] I
miss doing that stuff and seeing you
know [__] neurotic people and crazy
people and uh
I don't know
you know what I miss most about living
in La this is going to be weird you know
what I miss Puerto Ricans
you know what I mean they just don't
have any Puerto Ricans out here I don't
know what it is not that there's
anything wrong with Mexican people but
you know L.A could use some Puerto
Ricans
and [__] women are gorgeous I was on
the subway or in a restaurant I was like
God damn look at her and I was like
that's right
Puerto Rican women
that's what's been missing from my day
to day
plus New York you know what I mean not
everybody's not hiding in cars you know
they're [__] on the Subways and [__]
walking down the street a bunch of Cutie
Pies
I don't know anyways
so but you know what I do love about
living out here I love when it's like
the level that has been that it has been
snowing
back on the east coast to just drop into
that and actually be excited to see snow
you know skipping down the street
wanting to make a snowman and [__] and
everybody else is totally miserable
there's nothing more fun and everybody
back East you probably at this point if
you're you know over the age of 22 or 23
you have that douchebag east coast
friend that moved to Southern California
or someplace warm
and you know what we do right you know
we do we just wait for a couple two we
we time it right not during the holidays
during the holidays we're on radio
silence because that's when we're
missing the winter right all the [__]
win all the [__] Christmas songs are
all about snow right just hear those
sleigh bells ring a link ding ding ding
a link to it's [__] snowing and right
snow
what the [__] what the [__] what the
[__]
you know I wonder how Native Americans
relate to that [__] Christmas music
right
is why people are sitting there singing
up giddy up giddy up let's go you used
to live here then we committed [__]
genocide yeah oh now we have a [__]
house where you used to [__] live
you know the nerve of us to write such
happy songs on the same land that that
[__] horror happened
foreign
oh you know Dasher and Dancer and
printer and Vixen
the Cherokee the Sue The Crow and Apache
where did they go
um
anyways uh so you know the deal so we
love to [__] call up
in January and February
the best time to do it is right at the
end of January when these poor [__]
back east no they got another month of
this [__]
right
it's just desolate right you've already
the high of a new year you've already
[__] up your New Year's resolutions
and you're just coming out right with
your [__] ice scraper
every [__] goddamn one and then
that's when we call
acting like we don't know what we're
doing hey
what's going on dude how are you yeah
how about them Bruins they're starting
to finally [__] play you know a seed
or whatever
they gotta rebuild kids so uh you know
what's going on about back there right
you do the whole [__] thing you know
Jesus and that's when you get the hit ah
oh what out here oh yeah
yeah I don't you know I haven't looked I
think it feels like about like 68
degrees
yeah I'm standing out here wearing a
hoodie and pajama bottoms taking my dog
for a walk
probably gonna go on a hike a little bit
later get a breakfast burrito
[Laughter]
I [__] love it
I absolutely love it and then when I get
to go back
you know you visit winter
you visited for a few days you know you
[__] you know get yourself a hot
chocolate you go skating or whatever you
do your little [__] thing I love
watching people back East digging out
digging out their [__] cars
you know and just talk every [__]
year just talking about how sick of this
the snow
you know and I always want the person on
the other side of the microphone to be
like yeah but it's winter
you know people just do them in the
summertime oh my God this [__] heat
whatever yeah it's just summer it's just
summer
you understand
there's too many [__] people
we've put too much [__] up [__] in the
air and you're gonna have crazy weather
it's going to be crazy cold and it's
going to be crazy [__] hot
what would you rather do like I was
thinking the other day would you rather
have global warming or to have it go
back to the Ice Age
you know
would you rather have the [__] the
water and I'm not saying whether we're
creating it or not oh you know I think
that without a doubt you can't have
seven billion people not have an effect
on the planet I know we are I went to
Asia I saw it
I breathed it in I held that tobacco in
my fingers I just sounded like [__]
Al Gore man when he ran for office
and he was trying to talk to people down
in Carolina going like I I tilled the
land I I held that the grass in my
fingers
now why the [__] would you ever say that
wearing a suit and wingtips
a bunch of dirty people staring at you
like what the [__] is this guy talking
about
huh what does he have a garden in the
backyard of his [__] Villa
um
no I just saw what
the direction we would but fortunately
the population over here is uh we're
keeping it at Bay but just the amount of
[__] that we buy
I think we create more waste or whatever
but I will tell you this dude like the
air quality over there was devastating
[__] devastating like I felt like I
was smoking five packs a day like I had
this scratchiness in my throat
when I was in Hong Kong and it got even
worse in in India and I'm not [__]
on either country and I'm not [__]
on the people there because I love both
countries and the people were awesome
but you know you got to admit the
[__] air quality
is uh it's horrific and right there
that's that is too many people having an
effect
on the yeah it happens
there's too many a one [__] thing
that's why you know these goddamn
diseases all of this [__] that we think
of [__] evil and all of that the
ebola's and
all of that [__] is is it's there for a
reason
so what's the great thing about nature
is it's all there it all serves a
[__] purpose
and the purpose of that [__] is to keep
us in line
you know what I mean that's what it is
but the Fatal flaw
is uh in nature is us
it's us we're too [__] smart for our
own good so rather than [__] you know
a bunch of us dying off like what
happens to every [__] goddamn animal
something happens if a disease doesn't
run through that that species of forest
fire gets them
you know we came up with medicine and
all of this [__] and there's a bunch of
people like I told you I should not be
here right now I should have died of an
append and a ruptured appendix when I
was in the sixth grade all right but
they got modern medicine and here I am
just taking up space
right I try I get a Prius
I recycle the water bottles but you know
they just throw them in the ocean I'm
just another [__] that shouldn't be here
walking around taking a [__]
that ends up in a lake
right
I don't know where the [__] I'm going
with this [__] but
um
the [__] I totally lost my look at this
I'm so [__] stupid I shouldn't even
be like if I actually had to live off
the goddamn land
I would be walking through the woods
tracking something to halfway through it
I would get distracted forget what I was
hunting and I would stop
to death right
isn't that how it works I don't know how
it works but anyways um
I love it I love that it's [__]
snowing back then there's all kinds of
[__] going on I didn't like that uh that
ice rink
back in Massachusetts collapsed thank
God there was no kids out there skating
or anything like that
um
you know Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ that would have been
[__] brutal but there's all this [__]
going on back then I don't understand
how this works but there's been so much
snow
that I guess they have in this problem
my heart goes out to everybody back
there because I've had water damage in
my house and it is a [__] nightmare
is a [__] nightmare but basically
there's so much snow up on the roofs and
then it starts to melt during the day
and then at night it freezes
so then what happens is during the day
when it starts to melt again for some
reason I guess it melts down at the
surface which makes no sense I figured
that'd be the coldest or whatever the
snow at the top trickles down somehow it
gets underneath this bed of ice and then
there's no it can't run off the roof and
it So eventually just gets absorbed into
the roof and starts leaking down so
they're doing this thing where they're
starting to clear off the roots and
roofs and they put these salt socks up
there
they never had that [__] when I was a
kid I never heard of that I guess you'd
take a tube sock you fill it up with
some of that rock salt and then you just
lay it down on the roof and somehow I
don't know about that I don't even I
don't get out I don't get how it [__]
works but there's a bunch of [__] back
there because everybody's house
is um
you know
getting water damage they're in a panic
and they're charging thousands of
dollars to go up there can you imagine
[__] doing that the [__] piece of
[__] people some old person who doesn't
want to go up there
or just in general if you've got some
kids and stuff I mean you know you don't
go up on the roof anyways if you've got
a wife and kids right but the [__]
you're not going up on a snowy roof and
these [__] [__] are charging all
that money hey I [__] hate when
people do that just start was it price
gouging is that what they call it
shouldn't the president step in
right then
that's what I do if I was President I
would find out who the [__] was doing it
and I would audit all of them
um all right this is the Monday Morning
podcast everybody from sunny California
oh yes Monday morning podcast and I'm I
don't have [__] to do today after I get
this [__] podcast done I'm gonna go
play some drums I gotta tell you I did
another one of those goddamn comedy jams
I'll tell you about that after these
messages from our other classes
um
oh [__] what was I going to tell you
guys about oh speaking of that posters
speaking of posters
Oh Billy redface guess what guess what
guess what my Southern tour
I think tickets might even be on sale
right now
I'm so [__] excited about this we're
doing the bus tour we're bringing the
bus back the back the bus is back I
don't know
um
I got to think of I need you guys help
on this one because I need to come up
with a name for the for the bus tour
I'm going down through the South
and uh and then also I also also I also
um mentioned that I was gonna start
possibly doing I was gonna have a big
announcement about I'm gonna start doing
a podcast every random Thursday maybe
like twice a month I don't know how I'm
gonna do this and I also need a name for
that one
um
I have a hell of a time trying to come
up with that [__] I'm not good at that
I'm gonna run my [__] mouth all right
here we are I'm on Bill Burr
shows all right here we go
for those of you who are at your cubicle
right now and you got to pretend that
you're working and you're actually on a
phone call I'll read you the dates that
we got up here so far
um that are on sale all right April 10th
I'll be in Miami Beach Florida
at the Fillmore Miami beach at the
Jackie Gleason Theater and I played this
place before and I didn't go upstairs
they have Jackie Gleason's office up
there with a bunch of stuff that he had
uh left over you know that whatever when
he died they just kept it there it's a
little Shrine and I didn't know about
that until after I left
and I remember someone's like hey did
you go up and see it I was like I was
[__] pissed I didn't because I used
to love watching The Honeymooners and I
love the Jackie Gleason Show
um
anyways April 11th I'll be in Tampa
Florida at the Ruth
eckerhead Hall Ruth eckerhead Hall I
don't know the [__] you say that um for
two shows April 11th all right and then
the southern tour starts for some reason
Miami I mean uh Florida is not
considered part of the South even though
they were part of the Southern tour last
time
we did uh we did Tampa then we went up
to uh Tallahassee to Florida State I
believe so anyways April 18th I'm going
to be in Savannah Georgia
um April 19th Knoxville Tennessee it
[__] kills me then I'm going there
and it's not football season
that's on my bucket list to go to a
Tennessee volunteer Game man
see that Purina catch out end zone that
checkerboard thing watching everybody
going nuts down there
um
Chattanooga Tennessee April 20th Memphis
Tennessee April 21st and I know what
you're thinking how come you didn't go
to Nashville because that's not what
this tour is about
everybody who goes to Tennessee goes to
Nashville and then every [__] in
Tennessee who doesn't live there has got
to drive over to Nashville guess what
they're sick of going to Nashville
Knoxville Chattanooga and Memphis all
right
April 26th I'll be in Huntsville Alabama
all right April 27th Jackson Mississippi
all right
um
May
was it May 1st Evansville Indiana well
that's not the south ah whatever we
always got to throw one wild card in
there who the [__] goes to Evansville
nobody
all right
um but just to let you know there's
there's going to be some more dates in
there
um we got some uh I think I think I got
at least one other Mississippi date I'm
so [__] excited about this I ABS did
I tell you guys how much I love the
[__] South have I ever told you that
huh all the old cars you see that
[__] people know how to fix up
driving around out there all the great
barbecue all these [__] awesome
places to eat the [__] music
I I absolutely I [__] love it down
there and I um
I can't wait to go down there so anyways
uh so the tickets are on sale actually
the Memphis Tennessee Huntsville Alabama
and Jackson Mississippi those are not on
sale yet but Evansville Chattanooga
Knoxville Savannah Tampa
and Miami Beach are all on sale and uh I
might as well keep going here for people
who aren't in the South I'm playing The
Wilbur in Boston Massachusetts I'm doing
a whole week I'm doing a week run Bill
Burr at the Wilbur all right
tickets have been selling
unbelievably
um
where we've sold 13 shows out if you can
believe it and we're going to add a 14th
and uh let's go I'm gonna tell you that
week's gonna be a rough one you know
uh because I'm gonna be [__] seeing a
bunch of friends I love that's gonna be
so [__] awesome yeah that's what it
all comes down to it all comes down to
the [__] friends I see that I meet on
the road and the [__] cigars I smoke
although I've been keeping that in line
this year uh going easy on the cigars
going easy and the last date I have here
is June 26th and 27th
um I'm gonna be at the Mirage casino in
Las Vegas and my new hours coming
together
I just did knighted too many stars and I
was backstage going what do I do do I do
a couple of leftover bits
um
do I do a couple leftover bits from my
last special that didn't make it
or do I go with some new [__] and I just
said [__] it I'm going with my new [__]
[__] it I'm not doing another special
for another year and a half like I won't
come up with another 10 minutes I know I
can do that and uh
I don't know that's my philosophy [__]
that you go hard
come out with your best [__] and just
have faith that you're gonna come up
with something else
um I hope I did the Material Justice
it was uh it was a really fun it was a
really fun set and uh there was somebody
famous in the crowd that was just
[__]
nothing
it's got nothing which always [__]
kills you like they're famous they know
things
you know but anyway so that I'm really
excited about that and uh like I said uh
Jason lawhead Paul verzi I got the whole
[__] crew coming around again
uh we got coach coming out uh Jay Law
heads Hall of Fame uh
high school basketball coach dad's
coming along and uh we got it all worked
out couldn't get the same bus driver
which sucks he's uh I don't know I think
we thought it was going to be in May at
first but now it's going to be in April
and he's driving a Band Def Leppard
actually through Canada so he can't be
there but that stinks so we'll get him
next time but he recommended somebody
that hopefully we're gonna get we'll
have a good time blah blah blah blah
blah and all that [__] so
um I need a name for the tour I'd love
to hear your suggestions and
um
let me see what else you know what the
easiest way to do it just send it to the
um
which I don't [__] have of course
because I'm a dumb [__] oh this this
podcast you know what this was a good
podcast right up to the left it just it
the whole [__] thing just went off
the rails how dumb is it that I don't
even know
I don't even know what the Twitter
handle is for my own [__] podcast do
you realize how [__] not even sad at
this point don't don't you guys yeah
bill yeah we expect that out of you we
expect that lack of professionalism at
the m m
podcast is that what it is
what is it
oh go [__] yourself bill you you suck
you just [__] suck
I'm the worst I don't even know what it
is somebody find it and then [__]
tweet me it so I know what my own
goddamn I can't even find the thing I
follow it it should be coming up
is it at the mm podcast
I'm sorry you guys have to listen to
this
there it is I got it all right so at the
mm podcast
um if you could just tweet me your ideas
for the name of the Southern tour and um
I already know some of you are going to
be a little wacky with your ideas slap
it on the knee there
um for that or the Thursday podcast
um even if I don't use what you have
I'll be a nice jump off point for me and
um I can actually come up with something
I'm going to come up with a real cool
tour poster I'm going to sign all of the
posters
and I'll be out there during the
southern tour uh you know shaking hands
kissing babies and all that [__] and uh
all I ask you guys you just tell us
where to go get some drinks and where
the cool places are to eat
um
and we do not want to go to any chains
we want to go to the [__] spot and if
the spot is the [__] if the local mom
and pop place is the [__] I promise you
I will not tell anybody about it
because you know as much as the Food
Network and all them you know they have
their heart in the right [__] place
uh
you know they end up blowing up the
place and then every douche like me
comes to town you know with my [__]
flip-flops and a brochure and then you
can't get a seat there anymore so I
won't do it I won't do that to you but
uh if you could let us know that would
be [__] tremendous
um so anyways I just mentioned that I'm
trying to keep my cigar smoking
I'm trying to get it under control and
uh it's actually scary how many I've
already smoked this year to actually
count them I've smoked 13.
so far
and that is a lot so I'm thinking last
year where I didn't even pay attention I
easily smoked over 100 [__] cigars I
must have
every three four days I would think so
sometimes I go you know and then you
know sometimes I go like 10 12 days but
then I go on like a three day run if I
was hanging with versie or something
like that and uh I know it's bad I know
I gotta stop and
there was uh you know Leonard Nimoy
passing away his last [__] tweet is
uh don't smoke I wish I didn't
something like that live long and
prosper and uh
you know the guy was like [__] 83 84
years old
and even then if you're lying on you do
you think you know as a young person
you'd be like ah man that's a great run
I'd love to [__] live that long but
when you're [__] facing it at 83 84
and it's still too early
you know what I mean I just think if if
you die because of your lifestyle
I think that's a tough one to get over
when you lie in there you know it's one
thing if you just
you know something tragic happens that
that's not your but if you were actually
shoveling something into your [__]
mouth that caused you to die earlier and
spend less days on Earth I mean that's
got to be a [__] just the fact
that the guy at 84 still had a little
bit of regret
um about that that was really an
eye-opener so
I was trying to do one cigar
a week this year which is still 52
[__] cigars right that's [__]
ridiculous that's still unacceptable so
anyways so right now we're about nine
weeks in I should be on cigar number
nine and I'm already up to 13. this
should be all the way into April so I'm
actually gonna take this month off
I'm not gonna smoke any although
a buddy of mine's coming to town Friday
and they already said we're gonna smoke
well maybe after number 14. oh geez it's
a rough one you know
um
but anyways I gotta get this thing under
control I'm really gonna like I don't
have any cigars in my house anymore
uh
the the [__] humidor is shut down
you know whatever the [__] you call
humidifier that's for [__] singers
humidors for [__] yeah there you go
yeah that's shut down I'm not [__]
using that thing anymore and uh I've
been boozing way less every once in a
while I gotta shut it down but uh
anyways let me talk about the goddamn
Comedy Jam everybody
so last week I for the fourth time I did
it this is my favorite [__] show to
do and uh this time we did uh Guns and
Roses Paradise City I dressed up like
Steven Adler one of my favorite drummers
of all time
and uh it was really cool I watched a
bunch of old Guns and Roses videos just
to see how what he dressed like and just
watched how he played
um to do maybe a mini impression of him
which I don't think I did I I because
I'm not comfortable enough playing in
front of a
pack Club
playing live like this point to actually
throw in a little bit of an
impersonation of the drummer I'll get to
that level of comfort Comfort because
that's what I'm working each time each
time I play a little bit better but I'm
still at the point of like oh my God
don't [__] this song up
um which I always do which I always do
but uh this is what was the best that I
played
and I'm not gonna lie to you man for a
bunch of comedians we [__] killed it
for a professional band I don't know
but uh it was so much [__] fun and
um
I think I tweeted a couple pictures of
me dressed to Stephen Adler you know
what's [__] hilarious though was uh
he wore like a lot of like tank tops and
[__] like that which I wasn't gonna wear
I'm too [__] self-conscious about my
pasty torso so he wore some vests and
[__] like that so I just had a white
T-shirt and I bought like this leather
vest and with the wig and the sunglasses
it looked funny right but I gotta tell
you at one point you know I was at home
by myself and I had the t-shirt on I had
on the leather vest and I put the
sunglasses on it and before before I put
the wig on I looked in the mirror and I
looked like Rob Halford
hahaha
you know not to say he doesn't look
good in a vest I'm just saying I
shouldn't [__] on him um
yeah I cannot pull off a [__] leather
vest
that is that is a spec you need you need
hair to pull that off all right if you
don't you just I can't even tell you
what I [__] look like I look like
somebody Al Pacino would have talked to
and cruising back in back in the day in
that [__] movie
um
I would have bursted out laughing if it
wasn't so shocking
how [__] silly I looked
um oh yeah it was bad it was bad but
anyways I put the [__] wig on which
was actually a woman's wig you know it's
hard to find is a [__] heavy metal
long blonde wig they just didn't have
them was all black hair brown hair and
then they had one that was actually the
right consistency but it was his whitish
kind of hair looks stupid so I had to
[__] comb the thing down I looked
[__] ridiculous I looked [__]
ridiculous and everyone like you know it
was funny was when I came walking out uh
the drum in the band
Nick who plays bass when I sit in he
never he that when he gets to see like
well however I'm dressing up is as I
walk out on stage and I saw and that's
the hardest I saw him laughing so I knew
it was a uh it was a good thing so then
I just went up and I did a set and I
basically was defending Steve and at
Steven Adler saying that he shouldn't
have been kicked out of guns and roses
and I knew all this nerdy [__] about him
so uh
the crowd really enjoyed it and all the
while I was reading his autobiography
and I got as much as I love
Stephen Adler I got to tell you when I
read the [__] the book there was that
[__] junkie thing where he was not
taking responses it's like not once in
the book did he say like all right I'm
gonna admit on this day or on this gig
I was too [__] up to play and I played
really sloppy it was just he always had
some sort of a [__] reason but what I
liked about the book was because I read
Slash's book and I still felt like he
was trying not to piss off Axel because
the chance of a reunion was still there
and Axel's so [__] I guess touchy or
whatever what I did like about adlers
was he didn't give a [__] it seemed like
he didn't give a [__] either when he was
in the band he had this great story of
one night they went out to play
they went out to play live
and uh Axel goes out to sing and the
monitors were [__] up and he was just
like [__] this show and walked off stage
after two or three songs
and as he was walking by Adler he gave
him [__] and was like well Axel maybe if
you showed up for the [__] sound
check
things would have sound right you know
actually said then I yeah what have I
whenever I see [__] whenever I read
stuff about that band because I [__]
love that band it was just like I don't
know it's just awful watching how
everybody just [__] let that guy
spin out at least it seems that way
right you like how I've read so many of
those books I actually think I know what
happened in the band I'm going to shut
up now I sound like a total nerd but
anyways
um
is there anything else I wanted to talk
about this week before I get into your
questions
uh my momentarily mentioned that uh the
Bruins are starting to play better
thank God I mentioned neither too many
stars
uh uh what else what else I think that's
it
I think that's it
um all right let's get into uh let's get
into the uh the old questions here for
the week all right drummer article
you know I've seen this before somebody
sent this to me
said hey Bill this article has been
going around all week I'm sure someone
sent it to you it's about how drummers
are more intelligent
how does it feel to be the exception uh
uh he says just kidding go [__] yourself
so obviously he's [__] on me so
there's this new study that claims that
drummers
are actually
more intelligent than everyone so right
there that's [__] ridiculous that's
not true but it's basically it says that
uh because
well let me just read this thing
um according to a collection of studies
drummers are super smart due to a
variety of factors relating to being in
the Rhythm Section
so wouldn't that mean like the bass
player and the Rhythm guitarist or or
the piano player whatever [__] makes
up your Rhythm Section would all be
smarter
I don't know the news comes courtesy of
polymik
isn't the fact that I can't even spell
well I can't really say I'm a drum it's
just a hobby um who have compiled a
series of reports from Oxford and
Harvard oh University is to name a few
what they found was that the dude at the
back of the band isn't the head
scratcher that you might think he is in
fact he's more likely to be the smartest
of them all for example as researchers
at Stockholm's carolinska Institute
found that the drummers who kept a
tighter Rhythm also scored better on 60
question uh intelligent test this is a
reflection of better problem solving
skills which creates a positive impact
on those around them or they're just a
smart person who decided to play drums
so naturally they would score higher I I
don't know that I buy into that I think
that that's a uh
it's I think this article is a reaction
to all the the drummer jokes
um you know for those of you that aren't
in the play music or whatever musician
or I guess is what you'd [__] call it
those you play music hey for those of
you who play music
um
there's a bunch of drama jokes like uh
what do you call somebody who hangs
around musicians uh drummer
you know
um how do you know there's a drummer at
the door the knocking speeds up
I guess that's one of talking about our
timing or whatever but like it's there's
a lot of like drummers that are [__]
morons who just bash [__] and they're
not actually musicians
so I think that this is a reaction to
that to say like you're actually smarter
than the [__] lead singer and lead
guitarist you know I think that that's
just what this is so do I buy into it no
I don't I don't I think that there's um
you know I think that there's super
smart people that decide
that all right whatever get into music
some of them are drummers some of them
play the [__] oboe but I don't think
uh
I gotta admit you know I've met a ton of
drummers and it's just like meeting
people
some are cool some [__] some are
smart you know
I think it's just a yeah I don't buy
into it all right whatever there we go
all right how to not wreck your eyes
okay Bill you were 100 correct finally
if your eyes are trying to adjust for
flicker it wears out wears them out big
time
well that sounds very Medical
um for this reason you never need you
never read or study under a single
fluorescent bulb a buddy of mine lost
his Pilot qualification this way with
only one fluorescent bulb your eyeball
kills itself trying to dilate and
constrict at an impossible speed oh yeah
because it kind of like flickers because
I don't understand fluorescent bulbing
and I also don't understand why whenever
I go to Home Depot I accidentally buy
those every [__] time
I look all over the box I can't seem to
find where it says fluorescent anyways
oh what what is a regular light called
if it's not fluorescent what's the good
one the nice warm one that makes my eyes
go ah
I can see what does it make your eyes
build do Bill ah anyways my uh my
buddy's eye doctor told told him that
you have to study under fluorescent make
sure it's at least two bulbs or you'll
wreck your eyes
uh as he did his hope this helps
well you know I could help but somebody
help me [__] read that goddamn thing
um all right franchise
this is hilarious I'm finally allowing
enough time to get through all the
goddamn reads and now I have nothing to
say
about any of them
all right franchise Bill not sure if
anyone asked you uh
not sure if anyone's asked you think
before
once again
people not proofreading I already have a
difficult time reading out loud
Bill not sure if anyone's asked you what
you think before but if you could own a
current sports franchise
which would it be or if you had to
create a franchise for any sport in any
city which would you pick what would you
call the team what city could really use
a team in particular in a particular
sport thanks
um all right let's see here so I think
somebody's asked me this before all
right if I could
um
if I can own any sports team I'm like
most sports fans I would want to own a
sports team from the city that I'm from
and back in the day when I was growing
up I would then go to be the greatest
owner of all time and not only would we
win a championship we would win the most
championships of in the sport and during
the time that I own the team
you know
but unfortunately that dream has died
for me because not only do I have the
money but every Boston team has gone out
and won championships
and uh you know
so I I can't really I am I going to be a
better owner
than Robert Kraft no
the people over at the Red Sox right
the Bruins the Celtics you know
what am I going to do
I guess right now the team that I'm most
concerned about will probably be the
Boston Celtics and I would want them to
uh win a bunch of championships so they
stay out in front of the Lakers
um because the Lakers have you know
they've just won so many goddamn
championships since the 70s it's insane
and of course they count that one from
the the
baa or whatever the [__] it is which is
so [__] ridiculous but such a classic
La thing I actually think it's funny
that they do it because everybody out
here is patting their resume you know no
one's a [__] waitress they're all an
actress everybody's a director and that
type of [__] so all right you want to
say you got you got 16
we won an NBA championship before there
was an NBA oh did you how'd you do that
because we're in La
um so maybe that one I think but um I
think um
if I had to own any team I would it
would probably be a team in a city that
I love uh team that was probably great
when I was a kid but isn't anymore I
would maybe uh the turn the Pittsburgh
Pirates around
or the Baltimore Orioles even though
they had a great year last year
um
let me see that's a damn good question
it's a damn good question I think uh I
don't know there's so many [__] teams
I hate after a while if you watch enough
sports you [__] hate all of them you
just like your team
let's say just stank every goddamn year
I don't know you know back in the day I
was thinking like uh
owning a Canadian
um
hockey team because they haven't had the
cup there in so long it'd be cool to
bring it back obviously it wouldn't be
the Canadians and Maple Leaf fans are
such [__] [__] talking [__] I
wouldn't want them to see any success
either
and I got to be honest with you we
always lose to them in the gold medal
game in the Olympics and then they talk
all this [__] [__] you know what [__]
all those teams [__] them all
but if I had to pick one uh maybe I'd
bring Edmonton back
Calgary I like
there was a time believe it or not that
I actually used to like Vancouver before
we played him in the finals and then I
[__] hate him but enough of them have
left that I think they have a new
personality but they still have the
sadine twins there
um
oh I don't even know what why would I
not like that what because they're good
I don't know yeah I think I would just
be a HomeTown thing or like the
Pittsburgh Pirates or something like
that or maybe bring a championship to
Cleveland I think would be great to make
the Browns yeah maybe I'd take the
Browns
I make the Browns but I would tell
people to stop [__] eating dog
biscuits and that type of [__] that
would be that would be the trade-off
you have to come to the game dress like
a human being you don't go there and
humiliate yourself
thinking you're actually affecting the
defense of the other team like oh my God
[__] this 360 pound tackle that's going
to be pulling that I have to [__] get
crushed by to force the run back to the
inside [__] all that there's a fat
accountant eating a dog biscuit barking
at me that's really messing with my
focus man
um or you know maybe bring a football
team to LA but you know something I
don't think they deserve it
all right
[__] Southern California fans all the
way up to San Francisco and Oakland
they're [__] horrific
not all of them but just they're
horrible [__] people
who bring violence to the game and they
they beat up people who wear different
uniforms I mean just I mean somebody got
shot at like a [__] 49ers Raiders
like preseason game and what those
[__] [__] at the Dodger game did
to that family that father with a family
where they had a couple of kids that guy
guys he's brain dead basically
it's got permanent brain damage they
took the they took this
these kids dataway with these kids right
there there's no excuse you saw that he
was a father so [__] all of them they
don't deserve a [__] team
there you go
um
that answers that answers your question
all right name change
or not all right this is a crazy one hey
yo Billy I have heard you talk about
Isis a few times on the Monday Morning
podcast so I thought I'd ask your
opinion on something that's been
bothering me for a while now my husband
and I had our child in the fall of 2013.
throughout my pregnancy we spent a lot
of time trying to come up with the
perfect name and tried to make sure it
was a name that no one could make fun of
and why don't you just go with Susan
Kathy Karen all the classics no one's
going to give you [__] about those after
months and months of debate we finally
settled on the name Isis after the Bob
Dylan song
I don't understand what happens to two
parents between being a child
and being picked on and bullied and all
that type there's just something about
it when you become a parent you just
forget and you buy your kids stupid
clothes please beat the [__] out of me
clothes and then you give your kid a
name like Isis
let's just say Isis the terrorist group
didn't exist
all right isn't that like that's like a
when I was a kid Isis was I gotta look
this up that was like uh that was some
superhero that was a woman Almighty Isis
Isis Isis
right
or people who like name their kid like
Thor
all right Isis woman it's my search
hero this is gonna put me on an FBI
[__] watch list because Isis and
heroin and the same thing
um
images for Isis woman hero Isis TV
series 75-76 I remember that so you go
Almighty Isis Isis Isis and then she it
was like it was a rip-off of Wonder
Woman Isis DC Comics here we go
um
here we go
my slow ass internet
here we go Isis is a DC Comic superhero
God damn look at her whoa
holy [__]
I swear to God man
does any woman look better than a woman
that a guy draws
[Laughter]
um all right Isis is a DC Comic
superhero as well as a separate Egyptian
goddess also living in the DC Universe
the recent superhero character is
modeled closely after the main character
of the secrets of Isis a live-action
American Saturday morning television
program that served as the second half
of Shazam I remember that
Shazam Isis hour the television
character appeared in the late 70s DC
Comic publication
yeah I remember this [__] so that to me
that that that's what it was
um all right let me go back to your
question here
so uh well as you know a few months ago
after a few months after she was born
this stupid terrorist group who just so
happens to go by the name Isis is all
over the news Isis is actually a
beautiful name I shouldn't be making fun
of that
um I don't know all of the political
aspects of the group and I really don't
care all I know is that a year later
these people are still all over the news
and don't seem to be going away anytime
soon
I don't know these terrorist groups are
kind of like boy bands you know what I
mean they're [__] hot for a couple of
Summers and then they just kind of go
away you know
like um
like like Hezbollah is like [__] the
Backstreet Boys at this point
you know and Isis is like uh not the
Jonas Brothers
Jonas Brothers like Hezbollah right
or the al-Qaeda I'd say they're more
like the al-Qaeda and Isis is like uh
Isis wherever the those [__] people
are
whoever the new one is right that's who
they are okay all I know is that a year
later these people are still all over
the news and don't seem to be going
anywhere anytime soon we tried ignoring
it but every time we have to tell
someone our daughter's name we either
get a weird confused look or we get
someone who tells us she should start
going by her middle name
wow
who would say that to a mother
we have thought about
I guess I'm old enough that when I when
I heard Isis when I heard the just to
let you know when I heard Isis the
terrorist group I laughed at the name
because I was thinking like that's that
superhero that was a rip-off of Wonder
Woman
you know what I mean
anyways we have thought about having her
go by her middle name until all this
blows over but she just doesn't look
like anything other than an Isis to us
so we decided that would be too weird
one solution we have thought of is to
change your name to something that is
similar to Isis so she can still use the
nickname shortened version of her
current name but we won't have the word
Isis tied to her legally so my question
is this do we have do we let everyone
else win or go through all of the legal
and financial burdens of getting her
name changed or do we keep her name as
it is now continue to put up with all
the side comics and dirty looks and Hope
who would think that someone would name
a little girl
after a terrorist group what state do
you live in
and hope the terrorist group Isis
doesn't turn out into any bigger deal
than it already is thanks for the advice
and as always go [__] yourself
um
I say you stand strong at this point
that's what I say I say you stay with
the name it's actually a beautiful name
that's a beautiful name for a little
girl Isis is a beautiful name
um
I don't know I don't know what to tell
you
you know because then it's like all
right so we're going to be stubborn and
then
oh gee what a [__] situation because
then it's like
your kid's gonna be young enough that if
you switch it now it's not going to
remember
but if you go too long that would be
weird if all of a sudden somebody
changed my name to like Chuck
hey Charlie Charlie oh yeah that's right
that's my name hey how are you what's
going on that would be weird
um yeah that sucks
that sucks it also sucks that they're
making Isis out to be this huge [__]
deal
you know what I mean that we're focusing
all these billions of dollars on this
little ass [__] group
right
and meanwhile over here you know you
have people that took took control of
the food supply and from what I've read
have essentially turned it into poison
isn't that terrorist Behavior right here
you can't focus on that you can't focus
on bankers and all these [__] [__]
how about that [__]
I swear to God I don't understand why we
can't just [__] build [__] in this
country
fix our own [__] [__]
and look you know electric cars you know
the batteries and [__] they're going to
do just as much damage to the
environment is oil and gas are you know
they are but here's the deal if we do if
we [__] switch over to that [__]
and then we don't use oil they [__]
go bankrupt and if they go bankrupt all
these [__] that are literally on our
side can't fund the money into these
terrorist groups and then they [__]
go away
right
and then you can have a kid named uh you
know Hezbollah
batting next
Hezbollah Saunders
Hezbollah sounded
um all right yeah so I don't know that's
that's so that sucks I actually you know
something I kind of gave you [__] in the
beginning I actually feel really bad for
you
um because you love your kid you love
the name and then
that's all one thing
um
I don't know
I don't think Isis is going to be around
too long
I just think that they're uh
they're too desperate you know what I
mean
they're too desperate for attention just
the [__] that they're doing
they're really kind of hacky
cutting people's heads off lighting
people on fire it's always some
Sensational [__] thing you know what
I mean
like if they were a comedian they would
just be they'd have a catchphrase I feel
like or they'd wear the same clothes
every time they went on stage and they
[__]
you know they they're trying too hard to
be evil I feel
that to think they're actually gonna
They're Gonna Last they [__]
allegedly I mean who knows
once it goes through all the [__]
propaganda on all this [__] that person
they threw off the roof was allegedly a
gay guy and they were thrown off because
he was getting just like [__] animals
I just don't think they're gonna laugh I
think I think even they are too [__]
insane
to last is what I'm hoping
you know
and um
I don't know that's a rough one because
I think my whole life I will remember
the name Hezbollah I will remember the
name Al-Qaeda
will I remember Isis though I you know
there's a big boy band out right now I
don't know the name of it
oh man that's a [__] I don't
know I don't know what to tell you you
know what I might have to phone a friend
what do you guys think
let's take a vote
all right you got three things come up
with the name for my Southern tour help
me come up with a name for my Southern
tour I should say help me come up with
the name for the Thursday podcast
um
the Thursday Monday morning podcast
um and
help this woman make this decision ah
that [__] blows
imagine if you had a kid you just named
him Eddie some regular name and then
there's some new terrorist group over
there and Eddie somehow stood for
something
you know
eviction of you know [__] early in
the lopers except it worked with Eddie
ha ha ha
anyways um anyway shh
anyways uh so that's a podcast for this
week everybody came out right in about
an hour this week I'm psyched that my
Bruins are starting to play well again
you know trying to stay ahead of the
[__] Panthers
um
I'm really uh I don't know what to tell
you
I'm actually thinking about that Sports
question again
I would like to start an upstart League
an upstart basketball league there's
just too many [__] teams already
I would like to do that and bring a team
back have bring back like the Rochester
Royals
you know that'd be fun you know
something actually thinking about that
now that I rethink this question
um seeing how [__] awesome the fans
are when I went to a Oklahoma Thunder
game
is that right
is it the Thunder I can't remember some
sort of weather
I don't watch hoop wow my brain is fried
um
yeah Oklahoma City Thunder yeah just
seeing how [__] awesome their fans
were and just the stadium that they
built which was just Bare Bones nothing
crazy like the Staple Center and some of
these other places and the place was so
[__] loud
because uh you know how that wasted
space of luxury boxes and everything so
it's really contained and it's like
super loud
I think it would be fun to uh
bring a professional team to a place
like Rochester or something like that I
think that would be really badass
now that I rethink it and uh I'm psycho
into [__] college hoops right now
um
and it actually kills me when I was in
New York I didn't I I last second I
looked up to see when St John's was
playing and the game was already going
it was down at Madison Square Garden and
it could have [__] gone
ah that [__] bugs me anyways all
right I'm I'm okay Came In Like a Lion
and went out like a lamb by the way
March 2nd this is my 23rd anniversary as
being a stand-up comedian
living the dream coming up on a quarter
century when am I gonna buy myself for
my 25th anniversary
um all right that's the podcast for this
week go [__] yourselves
um I hope it doesn't keep snowing back
East even though it makes me laugh but
uh that is it I will talk to you guys
soon uh rest in peace Leonard Nimoy
um and